what do you think a vagina really sounds  like vocally  I think it's a masculine British man  hello Joe how's your day today will you  be entering me  open the gates I just want to punch it  now I don't want that Daniel Craig [ __ ]  talk that was Daniel Craig to you  that's a good question what would it  sound like a younger girlier version of  your girl I'm not touching that I think  when I say younger I mean like two years  younger not the same voice there's a big  difference all right you brought me back  you brought me back what if [ __ ] only  talks like Pitch Perfect style it's only  in acapella songs as long as they're not  matchups what if it's a rapping to you  no I don't like that b to the a to the r  to the e oh no I'd rather have a British  man's voice you look mighty chipper  today it's more comforting to me oh  that's a good Daniel Craig you like that  Bond James Bond